[Musik]
bei ihm läuft grafen maximal roms mit
seinem comedy programmen führt er die
ganz großen hallen das publikum liegt
ihm zu füßen
netflix hat seine chance auf specials
eingekauft den deutschen comedy preis
gewann bereits zwei mal im dezember
wurde sein podcast gemischtes hock den
er zusammen mit tommy schmid produziert
wieder zum beliebtesten spotify podcast
in deutschland in der schweiz gewählt
der einzige nicht englische podcast der
es sogar in die weltweiten top ten von
spotify geschafft hat sein buch sonne
und beton war ein bestseller und kommt
dieses jahr aus verfilmung ins kino ich
freue mich sehr dass er heute bei uns
ist felix recht herzlich willkommen
ich habe fünf kommen die presse ziemlich
viele preise ziemlich viel erfolg echt
viel erfolg sogar uns in der new york
times gab es auch eine lobeshymne auf
sie man fragt sich schon sind sie
eigentlich ein glückspilz oder ein
workaholic oder beides
also ich arbeite viel aber die meisten
das meiste meine arbeit für technisch
viel arbeit an deswegen kann ich
wahrscheinlich auch viel machen aber
ich glaub da gehört auch alles auf jeden
fall auch glück also es gibt viele
künstler irgendwie die in einer analyse
von ihrer eigenen karriere die variable
glück völlig rauslassen und das ist
ziemlicher blödsinn weil die härteste
arbeit bringt nichts wenn man nicht
irgendwie glück hat mit irgendein
irgendwas timing connection oder das
nicht was aber die geschichte die sie
über sich selbst erzählen haben sie
einmal gesagt sie hätten eigentlich vom
comedy keine ahnung gehabt und mal
ausprobiert von bücher und keine ahnung
gehabt dann wohl das ein bestseller ist
es nicht auch ein bisschen unser
statement als pr gag
ich glaube ich bin nicht für andere
statement bekannt aber
ich glaube ich nicht weil weil das
stimmt also es gibt comedians also ich
bin ja jetzt auch viel auf den ganz
kleinen shows unterwegs um sein neues
material zu testen uns oder lerne ich
hatte auch viele underground comedians
kennen und die haben unglaubliches
wissen über comedy so die können einem
jedes geiles special aus den usa von
1970 bis heute unter mehr oder weniger
kennen alle fachtermini kennen alle witz
strukturen aber sind in ihrem leben 15
mal aufgetreten so und bei mir war es
halt genau umgekehrt also ich kenne mich
also mittlerweile natürlich jetzt weil
es jetzt auch schon länger so mein job
ist aber ich habe mich erst als ich das
schon jahrelang gemacht habe angefangen
wirklich mit mit dem handwerk comedy
auseinanderzusetzen und bei buch
schreiben war es genauso ich hatte mal
eine phase meinem leben da habe ich
einigermaßen viel gelesen und für meine
verhältnisse
aber wie man ein buch schreibt oder
sowie dramaturgie funktioniert von sowas
habe ich keine ahnung gehabt es gibt ja
auch die geschichte wie sie eigentlich
angefangen haben und die geschichte geht
so dass ihr bruder eigentlich sie
angemeldet habe beim poetry slam und sie
wurden erst gar nicht ausgelost sondern
eigentlich kaum der typ der dann hätte
auf die bühne kommen sollen war da nicht
und wurde noch einmal nachgezogen und
sie waren dann dabei ist es nur eine
gute geschichte oder auch wirklich wahr
das ist tatsächlich so ich schätze es
erinnert sich niemand mehr daran aus dem
publikum aber wenn dann würde ich das
gerne mal jemand bestätigen lassen weil
das klingt natürlich sehr groß gedacht
aber es war wirklich genauso also ich
war nicht ausgelost das waren viel mehr
anmeldungen als als startplätze der
letzte startplatz kam nicht und dann war
ich auf einmal der letzte aufgetreten
ist und dann hat es für damalige
verhältnisse ok funktioniert und ab dem
moment wo ich so diesen ersten lacher
auf der bühne hatte war ich dann so
angefixt vom auftreten und habe dann
angefangen so für die bühne zu schreiben
was treibt sie den armen ist es die
bühne
ja also also meinem selbstverständnis
bin ich auf jeden fall mit weitem
abstand an erster stelle comedian
und auftritten ist auch das was mir am
meisten spaß macht und
jetzt gerade treibt mich eigentlich
einfach besser werden an also ich habe
lust besser zu werden als comedian und
besser wird man durch viele auftritte
und ich viele erfahrungen und sowas
ich habe mal gesagt zufriedenheit sei
ein
kreatives lebensgefühl das heißt
eigentlich ist unzufriedenheit das was
sie antreibt sie denken immer es geht
noch was er wahrscheinlich der spruch
ist nicht von mir ich hab dann und wo
geklaut ohne quellenangabe
irgendwann kommt dann kommt zwar ist
schöne grüße
ja also zufriedenheit im sinne von satt
sein glaube ich glaube wenn man satt ist
dann
ja dann also ich kann mir nichts
schlimmeres vorstellen als wenn man über
mich sagen sagen würde ich würde mich
auf meinem erfolg ausruhen ich glaube
das finde ich irgendwie wirklich kacke
und
solange ich irgendwie immer noch so
hunger hat
wie man auch immer den definiert also
bei mir ist es jetzt gerade nicht primär
ökonomische oder sowas so finanziell ist
gerade alles okay aber ich habe den
drive und nicht als comedian einfach
besser werden oder ich will es ist ich
klamotten game abschleppen wir noch ein
buch schreibe ich will dass der film gut
wird ich will ich habe noch so viele
sachen die ich machen will und das hält
mich irgendwie am ball was heißt das für
sie als comedian besser zu werden ich
meine die haben die ganzen preise
gewonnen ihre tickets die sie da
verkaufen für die neue schau die waren
innerhalb von 24 stunden ausverkauft
woran würden sie bemessen dass sie noch
besser geworden sind ja also preise sind
wir ziemlich egal ehrlich gesagt dass
nur so
ist eine nette anerkennung aber es
bedeutet mir nichts ja wobei die letzten
beiden kommen die preise schon ein
bisschen weil das voting preise waren
aber jetzt also das interessiert mich
eigentlich nicht so
naja besser wird also
ich finde je mehr ich es schaffe mich
selber auf die bühne zu bringen ohne
mich zu verstellen desto besser werde
ich als comedian also bin ich als
comedian fündig ja dann halt einfach so
objektiv messbare sachen wie wie viele
lacher kriegt man wie doll sind die
lacher wie lang kann man eine sache
reiten sowie kreativ ist eine prämisse
also wie überraschend ist die pointe
und auch einfach so die die themen die
ich bespreche soweit also ich hatte vor
drei vier fünf jahren teilweise ideen
für sachen die ich jetzt ins neue
programm nehme weil ich mich damals noch
nicht dann getraut habe weil ich noch
nicht das gefühl hatte irgendwie das so
erzählen zu können das wirklich dass man
wirklich versteht wie ich das meine also
das heißt für mich besser werden dass
ich das ich themen besser auf den punkt
bringen kann die irgendwie ein bisschen
komplexer oder ewiger sind oder was auch
immer und dass ich nicht das gefühl
haben muss mich auf der bühne zu
verstellen kommen wir zurück zur frage
glückspilz oder nicht um die man
überhaupt so im leben steht es gibt ja
so das große thema des live hacks das
immer wieder auftaucht in ihrem podcast
sind gewischten hakt es gibt auch
hockeys also die comedy quasi leute die
das gucken die haben ganze seiten auf
instagram zum beispiel wo man diese live
hacks angucken kann und die idee eines
live hacks ist ja sowas wie so ein
praktischer tipp der einem hilft besser
durchs leben zu kommen da gibt es ganz
konkrete dinge wie zum beispiel dass sie
ihre wäsche auf bügeln trocken lassen
dass man adiletten einpackt wenn man ins
hotel geht damit man sich mehr zu hause
fühlt und so weiter aber es gibt auch
philosophische rex zum beispiel haben
sie irgendwo wenn man sich
neujahrsvorsätze macht dass man sich
möglichst quantifizierbare ziele selbst
soll weil dann hat man nicht so was sie
ich möchte mir lesen sondern ich möchte
zwei bücher pro monat lesen und dann
wird's eben die einfache sich daran zu
hoffen was sind diese hacks für sie ganz
persönlich ist das etwas was sie selber
wirklich befolgen sagen sie so jetzt hab
ich hier so eine idee und die ziehe ich
jetzt auch durch das hat eigentlich
angefangen als irgendwie so ein podcast
gaga inflation also das war jetzt nicht
so krass überlegt essen und es hat den
leuten dann gefallen haben uns auch
viele leute und wieso sachen zugeschickt
die dann wirklich auch einfach eine gute
idee waren also teilweise sind das
wirklich und viele gute ideen
ich ja also meinem leben spielen so live
hacks keine große rolle das hat jetzt
das wirklich größtenteils der podcast
aber so also dieses mit quantifizierbare
ziel oder so was ich weiß ich hab ich
das als live-act bezeichnen würde aber
das einfach so was was ich an mir selber
gelernt habe dass mir das hilft wenn man
sich relativ konkrete ziele setzt also
etwas abstraktes wie ich will mehr sport
machen so ja ok aber wenn du letztes
jahr gar nicht trainiert hast dann hast
du jetzt dann geht's am 2 erst einmal zu
mcfit hast mehr sport machen
ja ich meine also soweit ich finde dann
so messbare ziele auch besser nach
nachverfolgbar so ich glaube mich
interessiert an diesen live hacks und
schon noch wie sie das im podcast machen
trotzdem auch sich noch mal zu überlegen
woher kommt eine idee und die kommt aus
dem silicon valley eigentlich
ursprünglich der live und die haben ja
schon die idee man kann eigentlich alles
lösen alles auch das leben an sich kann
man knacken kommen hätten wir könnten ja
unsterblich werden glauben einzelne
forschende im silicon valley und das ist
das was mich irgendwie so ein bisschen
unruhig und zappelig werden lässt weil
ich ihnen die denke es geht nicht darum
dass leben zu hacken es geht nicht darum
alle probleme weg zu machen sammelt die
probleme sind gerade das was uns
irgendwie menschlich macht ja zumal so
ein leben ja auch nicht 10 codiert ist
also dieses dieses kommt diesen diesen
computer ansatz von problemlösungen weil
so problem und lösung 10 codiert ich
glaube das ist das leben überhaupt nicht
übertragbar bekommt also probleme im
leben einerseits viel komplexer sind und
ja auch eigentlich nie gelöst sind
sondern
gesundheit
dann irgendeinen einfluss auf den
weiteren verlauf haben das dann ja neue
probleme auf macht also ich bin auch gar
kein fan von vom von diesem silicon
valley way of thinking und problem lösen
und ich glaube auch überhaupt nicht dass
technik irgendwie die
wirklichen fuß also die philosophischen
fragen dem leben und wie löst man
eigentlich haben menschen ja immer
dieselben probleme gehabt so und ich
glaube wir sind auch im moment selber
hat das größte problem dir selbst und
zwar die art und weise wie die jungs
eben nicht verändern sie haben in einem
podcast episode haben uns darüber
gesprochen dass sie den vielen don't
look up interessant gefunden haben ging
mir auch so also dieser film der am 24
zwölfter auf netflix gestartet ist ein
film in dem gezeigt wird dass die
menschheit herausfindet eigentlich zwei
forschen dort aus ein riesiger meteorit
auf die erde knallen wird wir werden
alle aussterben das wird zu ende sein
und jetzt könnte man sich ja überlegen
naja wir raufen uns zusammen und finden
eine lösung aber was passiert die mächte
glauben eigentlich diesem einen tag die
ganzen der die idee hat er will diesen
meteoriten sprengen um die rohstoff
herauszunehmen nun noch reicher zu
werden also eigentlich was wir wirklich
bräuchten aus hack wäre uns zu hacken
dass ihr mal wirklich hingucken was die
wahren probleme sind ja das meine ich
damit also ich glaub dienen also die
menschen haben eigentlich seit jeher die
selben probleme und die kann man ja
offensichtlich anscheinend nicht lösen
also eigentlich ich habe das gefühl dass
der linken valley ist eigentlich nur am
am symptome lindern überall ohne das
wirkliche problem anzugehen und das
wirkliche problem sind ja dann auf die
subjektive eben einfach so beziehungs
sachen und so also diese sachen da wird
er nie irgendwie eine technische lösung
für geben so oder oder verteilung von
wohlstand und das ist also das ist ja
einfach technisch nicht lösbar
das ist ja durch technik teilweise sogar
befeuert also extrem bevor er sogar so
also ich was ich an don't look up
einfach cool fand war dass der
also ich mag es immer wenn kunst im
weitesten sinne
nicht nur eine message hat sondern auch
einfach gut gemacht ist es war einfach
ein unterhaltsamer film so und die
besten comedians finde ich
es gibt der trend entwickelt sich hat so
ein bisschen so eine richtung das ist
eigentlich nur noch es geht immer nur
noch um message und agenda und irgendwie
auf der richtigen seite stehen und sowas
und dabei wird völlig vergessen witzig
zu sein beispielsweise im comedy kontext
und die besten comedians sind halt die
die beides können also die irgendwie
eine coole message verpacken raushauen
aber du auf dem weg dahin zwölf mal
wirklich lachst so und ein guter film
mit einer message ist einer der sich
währenddessen auch kraß unterhält das
fand ich einen anderen look absolut es
sehr interessant weil das stimmt ja
generell für die kunstwelt also auch
wenn man eine zeitgenössische kunst
ausstellung ansehen geht dann ist sehr
oft die message unglaublich wie stöhr
und gar nicht mehr das ästhetische
vergnügen wir sind ja auch ästhetische
wesen das heißt wir wollen auch sinnlich
angesprochen deren rahmen lachen ja und
ich finde ich finde halt der bloße
inhalt rechtfertigt die form nicht also
gebt euch trotzdem müssen die wirklich
es gibt ganz viele leute gerade in
meiner branche die wirklich nur noch auf
message gehen und mir denke so das
willst du willst applaus oder willst du
lacher wenn du applaus weil es ganz okay
aber machen ted talks das ist kein
comedian so und das finde ich irgendwie
also mich langweilt langweilt ist total
sprechen wir über sie über sie geht ja
ganz oft erzählt dass die sonne
tellerwäscher karriere hingelegt haben
und ich muss zugeben ich habe mit diesem
bild ein bisschen problem und zwar
deswegen weil ich immer denke was ist
das eigentlich für ein bild das ist
nämlich das bild diejenigen von oben
gucken nach unten es gibt schon diese
trennung so zu sagen es ist völlig klar
wer unten ist er hat auch unten
anzufangen nämlich beim schmutzigem
geschirr eigentlich ein hässliches bild
ja also ich glaube den schlimmsten
artikel über mich hat mal die
eine sehr renommierte deutsche zeitung
geschrieben nämlich die schöne grüße das
war genau diese perspektive da war der
titel nämlich der millionär aus dem
ghetto und das ist so ziemlich die also
ich glaube das ist so eine eine
tonalität
unabhängig davon
habe ich wirklich früher teller
gewaschen weil ich viel in der
gastronomie gearbeitet habe und
also ist das macht es nicht weniger wahr
auch wenn die perspektive aus der das
erzählt wird vielleicht oft irgendwie
eine von oben ist aber sie oft das kommt
in jedem artikel wird derzeit wo sie
groß geworden sind dass gropiusstadt
neukölln im süden berlins da sind sie
aufgewachsen eine ein ort für diejenigen
das nicht kennen der fahrer ab den 1970
er jahren zum sozialen brennpunkt
geworden ist wie wichtig ist das für sie
persönlich für ihre biografie den
zehnjährigen k4 zellen also ich komme
aus rudow in neukölln
und
das ist eine komische gegend weil man da
auf der einen seite irgendwie den
sozialen wohnungsbau hat und direkt
dicht an dicht so einfamilienhaus
siedlungen es war irgendwie ein
komischer komischer clash
wie wichtig ist es für mich also ich bin
auf jeden fall
mag das wort patriotischen ja ich bin
ein stolzer berliner so aus berlin sein
ist auf jeden fall teil meiner identität
aus in köln sein dass auch teil meiner
identität
und offensichtlich habe ich das thema
beschäftigt man ich habe auch ein buch
darüber geschrieben und so ist hat auch
viele jobs früher darüber und habe auch
immer mal wieder referenzen auf die zeit
also ist auf jeden fall war es was mich
geprägt und geformt hat ich denke mir
nur manchmal
also wir wissen es ja jetzt ich habe das
gefühl diese geschichte wurde wirklich
erzählt langsam es muss nicht immer
wieder immer wieder da reingehen aber
die leute interessiert zahlt das ist
genau diese tellerwäscher story die die
leute halt fasziniert und
er hasst es halt so ein bisschen diese
diese diese diese dieser rags to riches
geschichte die die leute also leute
mögen ja einfach gute stories und mein
leben ist von außen betrachtet
wahrscheinlich von eine gute story und
sie sprechen ja auch oft über klassismus
und das ist ein thema was so ein
bisschen neuer jetzt immer stärker
diskutiert wird also die mangelnde
soziale mobilität die tatsache dass es
eine diskriminierung gibt aufgrund von
herkunft also nicht nur aufgrund von
rasse rassismus aufgrund von geschlecht
sexismus sondern eben auch den
klassizismus und das ist ein thema das
ihnen wichtig ist und das nimmt man
ihnen natürlich ab weil sie erzählen
können wie sie zum beispiel auf dem
gymnasium lehrmittel befreit war wie das
glaub ich heißt also das heißt sie
mussten die bücher nicht selber bezahlen
und die lehrpersonen haben dann extra
immer auch noch darauf hingewiesen
eine klassische erfahrung von rassismus
ja also ich also ich nenne es nicht
klassismus und ich will auch gar kein
mitleid in die richtung oder irgendwie
verständnis dafür dadurch für irgendwas
ich finde einfach nur also was mich noch
immer erstaunt ist also wir leben in
einer sehr
wachen also wogen zeit wo sich sehr viel
mit verschiedensten diskriminierungs
mechanismen und dimensionen
auseinandergesetzt wird sehr laut im
internet und
und dann einfach diese
evident wichtige und größte und beste
erforschte diskriminierungs dimensionen
nämlich soziale im sinne von
ökonomischer herkunft einfach nicht
thema es ist mir wirklich unbegreiflich
warum warum das nicht in die analyse mit
aufgenommen wird also
und es geht gar nicht darum irgendwie
anderen diskriminierungs dimensionen
irgend etwas wegzunehmen ich denke mir
nur aber also das ist auch wirklich auch
wichtig also es gibt ja nichts was
besser erforscht ist aus diesem aus
diesem gebiet als dass armut sich
reproduziert und armut mit schlechter
bildung zusammenhängt und so weiter also
nichts determiniert dein leben mehr als
deine sozialer herkunft und ich verstehe
nicht warum das einfach so wenig thema
ist da gibt es so gute studien zahlen
fakten drüber das ist mir wirklich
unklar also thema ist es ja zum teil
schon zumindest in der
bildungslandschaft aber interessant ist
gerade auch mit bezug auf die schweiz
dass man immer da sagt man tut
wahnsinnig viel aber wenn man schaut wie
die schweiz zum beispiel da steht im
internationalen vergleich dann ist das
nicht besonders rosig wir wissen zum
beispiel dass man bei genau gleich im
intellektuellen vermögen wenn man aus
einer akademikerfamilie kommt ein
ungefähr fünf vier bis fünfmal höheres
für ihre chance hat auf den gymnasialen
abschluss wenn man aus einer familie
kommt von nicht akademikern
obwohl man genau gleich intelligent ist
und solche dinge sind natürlich stufen
jajaja oder auch so einfach so
erschütternde zahlen dass leute die
irgendwie
so aus wie sagt man jetzt prekären
verhältnissen kommen einfach zehn jahre
weniger lebenserwartung haben also in
ländern wie deutschland als ist ja
wirklich sehr sehr voll der kopf ich
eigentlich
nicht meine ich glaube auch nicht dass
es ein nicht thema ist ich finde nur
also ich nehme es auf jeden fall in
keiner relation zu den anderen themen
also zu den anderen ist man war in der
öffentlichen debatte so gerade was diese
ganzen wauquiez und in deutschland gibt
funk und wie also diese da findet es
nicht vergleichbar viel statt vielleicht
könnte man sagen dass fehlt irgendwie
die lobby das ist ja interessant weil
sie gesagt haben ja wo gesellschaft es
gibt natürlich eine sehr starke
feministische bewegung es gibt eine
starke antirassistische bewegung die
verbünden sich auch an vielen orten
wobei es natürlich jetzt neuerdings
global gesehen auch eine feministische
bewegung gibt die genau versucht
zusammenzudenken rasse klasse und sechs
kinder davon tragen oder gezogen diese
intersexualität forschung also
intersexuellen für mindestens wobei
ich glaube ich glaube man müsste
intersexualität von der sozialen
herkunft ausdenken und das dann mit
anderen diskriminierungs dimension
kreuzen und also feminismus intersection
half - muss denkt er quasi vom
geschlecht aus so
aber vielleicht wie es mir ist ganz kurz
klären inbegriff der vor allem von bell
hooksiel geprägt wurde die idee dass man
sozusagen doppelt und dreifach reformen
von christie's kriminellen erfährt wenn
man eben entsprechend nicht die richtige
hautfarbe herzen nicht aus der richtigen
klasse kommt oder eben nicht den
richtigen geschlecht angehört das ist
das zusammenwirken verschiedener
diskriminierungs dimension und ich
glaube es ist ein englischer begriff
also von interception also vom kreuz
sondern also von kreuzungen
verschiedener diskriminierungs
dimensionen so und das finde ich auch
ein einleuchtendes konzept ich glaub ich
glaube aber dass man also ich glaube
dass man das von fr sozialen herkunft
aus denken sollte und dann von da aus
quasi die die die die sachen und
was vielleicht auch noch mit reinspielt
ist wie wir schon gar wie ich schon
gesagt habe und was ja auch nicht als
meine meinung ist dann auch einfach gut
erforscht ist dass armut und bildung
sehr stark zusammenhängt und diese
debatte auch also diese diskriminierung
debatte auch sehr akademisch geführt
wird und ich mir deshalb vorstellen
könnte dass das betroffene leute aus den
prekären verhältnissen einfach
inhaltlich gar nicht mit drin sind weil
sie sich gar nicht auf
wissenschaftlicher basis mit diesen
themen auseinandersetzen weil die gar
nicht erst da hinkommen so war das für
sie ein grund an die uni zu gehen und zu
sagen ich studiere jetzt mal nach vwl
und politikwissenschaften weil sie da
auch dieses rüstzeug sozusagen wie sich
noch sicher arbeiten wollten ich habe da
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so krass
darüber nachgedacht ich hab' ich fand
meine bildungslaufbahn ist ziemlich
messi und hatte tausende umwege aber
irgendwo irgendwann hatte ich mal
politikunterricht und fand den cool hat
dann das abitur nachgeholt weil ich das
dann gern studieren wollte
und ich habe das wirklich einfach aus
interesse studiert so
hab dann an der uni ähnliche erfahrungen
gemacht wie das eine jahr wo ich auf dem
gymnasium war
für die auch immer nur so der der von
jung aus berlin war so dass sie kind
kann man so eine geile szene da waren
wir erst die woche also
erstsemesterwoche dann marburg in wo ich
studiert habe es eine kleine uni stadt
das ist ein riesiges thema die ganze
stadt ist auf den beinen alle sind am
saufen blablabla und dann war ich mit so
einer ersten gruppe unterwegs standen
schon mehr und viel da draußen haben
bier getrunken und dann kam so andere
leute und haben so geraten was wir jetzt
studieren weil da haben die wirklich auf
einen nach dem anderen hier weiß ich was
politikgeschichte medizin anzeigen die
auf mich sagen gar nicht
so komisch so komische situation hatte
ich irgendwie an der uni ganz ganz viel
und
ich hab da war ich dann mit zunehmender
semesterzahl erstaunt weil wir zum
beispiel kritik der
geschlechterverhältnisse waren pflicht
module im ersten semester das fand ich
spannend erst hab ich mich natürlich
erst mal so ein bisschen gegen gewehrt
weil ich halt einfach keine ahnung von
dem thema hatte somit derzeit van ist
entspannend und war auch froh dass ich
das gelernt habe und dann ging es noch
viel und dann gab's halt ein modul nach
dem anderen zu allen möglichen
diskriminierungs dimensionen an dass sie
wirklich cool jetzt kommt vielleicht
noch sozialer herkunft das war einfach
nie thema und irgendwie wie erschütternd
es muss man sich dann so voll selber
suchen und sie bringen es dann aber auch
auf die bühne und es gibt im letzten
programm hype gibt es eine stelle wo ich
es gedacht habe das ist irgendwie der
moment wo man klassismus auch nochmal
versteht da geht es ja nicht um geld und
es geht darum das ist eigentlich so was
so eine schnöde position ist zu sagen
ich mache mir nicht viel aus geld und
das muss man sich erst einmal leisten
können und genau das thematisieren sie
wir gucken ganz kurz an
zum beispiel ist zb das erste mal in
meinem leben geld ja ich hatte nie geld
jetzt habe ich geld
und geld ist cool
kann ich empfehlen ja ich empfehle euch
geld
wie spät es ist
[Gelächter]
also laut man noch voll goldenen 42.000
euro rolex kurz nach bei mir läuft danke
der nachfrage
weil ich kann nach der show jemand zu
mir meinte so felix die show war nicht
gut aber dann hat mich die ganze zeit
geblendet
gedachte dicker weise wie man sowas
nennt luxusprobleme
hätte den spruch more money more
problems stimmt nicht das ist eine lüge
so die schere zwischen arm und reich ist
auch nur auf der eigenen klinge scheiße
also
das ist ja total kunden der
entschuldigung ich spreche leider
wirklich kein amish und
sie sprechen kein englisch
doch wer klar ich würde mich auch immer
auch mit mehr geld immer immer zu den
leuten dazu zählen als irgendwelchen
rich kids aber was bewahrt sie denn
davor nicht selbst zum klassisten zu
werden weil sie haben jetzt auch dass
sie fahren mercedes sie trocken teure
markenklamotten sie können sich eine
rolex leisten kann man nicht plötzlich
auf der anderen seite stehen und nicht
mehr zurückfinden
kann man garantiert ich glaube es
passiert auch führen
ich habe einfach
also
das ändert nichts an meiner herkunft und
an meiner familiengeschichte und an
meinen freunden wie viel geld ich
verdiene momentan so ich
lebe einfach mehr oder weniger hat
dasselbe leben mit denselben leuten und
so was dieses hält an am boden finde ich
immer eine ziemlich arrogante
formulierung aber also das sorgt einfach
dafür dass ich eben nicht ab spacer so
ich mache keine promi scheiße so ich
hänge nicht auf irgendwelchen gala shows
rom ich häng mich mit irgendwelchen rich
kids umso ich koks nicht als ich mache
die ganze scheiße und das interessiert
mich alles nicht ich habe dieselben
freunde wie immer so ich mein vater
wohnt immer noch da wo wir wo wir
aufgewachsen sind also meine familie
wohnt trotzdem alle irgendwie in
berlin in normalen wohnungen meine
freunde alle normale jobs habe nichts
mit dem showbusiness zu tun so
ich wohne am kotti in kreuzberg so ich
bin nicht irgendwohin gezogen wo es
vielleicht ein bisschen sauberer ist
also ich ich ich
ich sorgt dafür dass ich am boden bleibe
so und am boden bleiben heißt auch eben
eben wie mit dieser geschichte in
kontakt zu bleiben und vielleicht noch
einmal zu ihrer lebensgeschichte sonne
und beton sie haben auch schon gesagt
sie haben ein buch geschrieben was zu
tun hat zumindest mit ihrer jugend man
muss auch sagen dass er immer gefährlich
von einer geschichte auf den autor zu
schließen kapitalfehler darf noch nie
machen und trotzdem ist es so sich
selber schreiben im buch ich wünschte
ich hätte mir mehr ausdenken müssen
steht am anfang des buches das heißt wir
gehen schon gemacht wie wir jetzt ein
cooler so ziemlich cooler satz macht
genau aber man macht natürlich daran
diesen rückschluss und fragt sich ja
dass der sound ihrer jugend weil da geht
es ja nicht nur um armut oder sozialer
segregation sondern es geht natürlich
auch um gewalt es geht um sehr viel
alkohol es geht um wirklich kinder oder
jugendliche die in sehr prekären
verhältnissen aufwachsen
ja klar also dass einst bei true stories
das ist nicht meine story manche sachen
aus dem buch habe ich eins zu eins so
erlebt manche sachen haben meine freunde
erlebt manche sachen waren so managen so
hat den abgestochen also diese
geschichten einfach und deshalb
komprimiert und verdichtet in einem buch
und ja das waren für so eine coole so
eine coole möglichkeit meine jugend
revue passieren zu lassen oder eine
phase in meiner jugend revue passieren
zu lassen und ich hätte das auch glaube
ich nicht früher schreiben können als
ich geschrieben habe also ich hab das
ich das geschrieben ab 2017 ist es
erschienen 2017 ist erschienen gott 2050
angefangen zu schreiben sprich da war
ich
kann nicht rechnen ja irgendwie 26 oder
so die hauptdarsteller in dem buch sind
14 15 16 und ich glaube diese zeitliche
distanz hat auch gebraucht um das
irgendwie und auch wie sich mein leben
verändert hat als ich es geschrieben
habe habe ich schon in marburg und die
politikwissenschaften studiert
größtenteils und erst mit diesem abstand
konnte ich diese sachen wirklich so
revue passieren lassen und selber wie
von außen sehen so
interessant finde ich auch immer wieder
das thema muskeln und sport und es gibt
auch als bisher bekannt von ihnen das so
dass pumpen muskelaufbau etwas ist was
sie auch immer wieder interessiert hat
sie haben noch mal gesagt sport ist eine
gute lebensschule unter anderem deswegen
weil er einfach zählt wer wie viel
gewicht die hoch kriegt und das kann man
nicht delegieren da kann man nicht
einkaufen dafür dass klein macht sondern
geht es um dich selbst durch anstrengung
also nicht wer viel wie wer viel
gewichte hoch kriegt in relation zu
jemand anderes sondern
also ich hab irgendwann gelernt dass
jetzt auch keine neue erkenntnis können
mittlerweile auch ein wandtattoo sein
aber
vergleiche um selber an irgendetwas
besser zuwenden um irgendwas zu wachsen
machen eigentlich nur sinn mit sich
selber das macht eigentlich nur sinn
sich mit sich selber zu vergleichen von
vorne woche vor einem jahr von dem was
ich was und beim sport ist es auch so
glaube ich ein mann ist ein eigener
gegner und wenn du nicht durch anstrengt
und dichter unter die gewichte liegst
dann passiert nichts also du kannst
diese aufgabe nicht delegieren und ich
glaube so ist es bei den bei allen
sachen im leben wo man in irgendeiner
form wächst und weiterkommen will am
ende muss man das selber machen man kann
sich nicht darauf verlassen also leute
die irgendwie aus guten verhältnissen
kommen konnte show verlassen aber leute
die sich aus guten verhältnissen kommen
nicht die müssen irgendwie selber
anpacken und können verantwortung nicht
delegieren ich finde sowieso immer sehr
und sexy
jetzt ohne also geschlechtsunabhängig
wenn leute wie sie ihr eigenes leben um
ein so andere hände geben also ich denke
also man muss selber irgendwie die
sachen angehen die einen stören und was
ich ja genau die these im klassisch
muster seinem das stört das sozusagen
die herkunft entscheidung nicht die
leistung genau das würde man sich
wünschen dass derjenige der sich bemüht
eine chance kriegt und war die gleiche
chance wie derjenige der hat anders
aufgewachsen
und im sport denkt man genau das ist
glaube ich die dimension die alle ist
man quasi gemeinsam haben genau dass man
das einem irgendwas in den weg gelegt
wird was man selber nicht beeinflussen
konnte das eben nicht die leistung zählt
und als ich auch im fußball immer wieder
das entscheidende oder das großartige
dass man menschen hat die großartige
fußballer werden das war ja die sage
sozusagen um maradona die großen
fußballer von denen man immer gedacht
hat ja die kommt von irgendwo her und
schaffens haut aufgrund ihres talents
und der leistungsbereitschaft
wenn wir noch einmal zurückgehen zu
diesem berlin was sie hier skizzieren
dann fällt ja auf es gibt auch ein ganz
anderes berlin wer heute als touristen
nach berlin geht der geht auch in die
hippen kiez in denen man irgendwie schön
kaffee trinken kann irgendwelche
öko kleider im shoppen und man hat ein
anderes bild von berlin und der man ein
gefühl dafür kriegen will dann glaube
ich eher lohnt es sich von sophie
passmann komplett gänsehaut zu lesen sie
war auch bei uns hier zu gast und ich
glaube sie zeigt in dem in diesem buch
anhand einer pizza ganz gut wie die
leute eigentlich sehr sich ihr image
oder ihre identität aufpimpen indem sie
eben nicht die klassische pizza essen
sondern die pizza mit dem gewissen extra
aus hören die ihr ganz kurz zu in der
pizza bricht sich die erzählerin aber da
muss ich auch ehrlich sagen auch für
mich
so eine art
sehr bürgerlich lifestyligen klassen
hass weil man dann sagt er pizza muss so
sein pitts also dann das allerneueste in
hippen stadtteilen von berlin das
übrigens sauerteig pizza die natürlich
auch noch mal drei euro mehr kostet dass
man dazu taten drauf ballert die
definitiv so so ein distinktionsmerkmal
sind dass man einen gewissen preis
erreichen muss für diese pizza damit man
auch eine gewisse klasse oder ein
gewisse schicht gar nicht mehr damit
erreichen kann unabhängig davon dass die
stadtteile in großen städten ohnehin
nicht mehr so durchmischt sind in der
regel dass man jetzt eine pizzeria für
ober- und mittelschicht haben würde aber
indem ich auf eine pizza ein ehemaliges
arme leute essen wieder in diesem buch
erklärt wird mit pinienkernen und und
irgendwie
gewickelt rote beete und einem für die
latte beschmeißt sorge ich natürlich
dafür dass die 14 euro kosten muss man
ja auch für schweizer verhältnisse und
witz ist aber das ist teuer und da da
geht es darum auch das ist
zugespitzt beschrieben aber da bin ich
schon fest davon überzeugt dass es bei
den kleinsten dingen in diesem
großstädtischen links liberalen
bürgerlichen milieu darum geht sich
abzugrenzen zu armen leuten ob man jetzt
pizza essen geht oder schuhe kauft oder
in die kneipe geht es geht immer darum
zu zeigen wer bin ich und vor allem wer
bin ich nicht
dies zeigen wir bin ich nicht ist es
etwas was sie es auch nervt von anderen
leuten
also erstmal nichts wird sich das so
viel dass man das erzählt wollen wir
kennen uns auch schon lange aber
spielte die gehaltvoll dazu schöne grüße
trotzdem
weil sie nicht ich habe mit diesem
ich habe dieser hit stuck nichts zu tun
so aber sie essen die normale petra
wichtiges gebiet wird erst im bereich
ist auch gern leckeres essen so so ist
nicht aber
ich möchte meine gut jetzt bin ich seit
irgendwie zwei monaten so mache ich
gerade mal wie kein fleisch essen aber
so mein lieblingsessen war jetzt
trotzdem und wie immer dünner gewesen
naja also etwas was mich wirklich nervt
sind und dass das ist ja quasi ein
symptom davon ist halt dieses klassische
thema gentrifizierung so dass
irgendwelche akademiker kids von sonstwo
irgendwie nach berlin kommen dann gehen
sie noch in unseren problembezirk
neukölln weil da die mieten noch billig
sind dann willst du alles teurer beim
glauben die wiederum 80 köln ist total
nett erzählen also
wenn die so
also ich finde halt wenn es gibt
gegenden in neukölln die wan in meiner
jugend no go areas für deutsche blöd
gesagt oder man also nicht langlaufen es
nicht sein musste als blonder so
und das ist ja total hipp begegnen so um
den hermannplatz rum oder sonnenallee
also teile von der sonnenallee teile von
der hermannstraße so diese das waren
früher teilweise no go areas und jetzt
ist es da und wie ein bisschen hip und
ein bisschen cool und es ist ja auch
schön so solange die leute die da uhr
sprich gewohnt haben dann auch irgendwie
sich das leisten können wohnen zu können
aber wenn dann leute irgendwie
dahinziehen oder ihre freunde die da
wohnen besuchen ihre hipster freunde und
dann findet in der weserstraße in kaffee
trinken und abends irgendwo in einer
kneipe und sind in sindorf getränken
oder wasserkraft bier und und dann aber
als so in die welt posaunt januar köln
ist ja gar nicht irgendwie so schlimm
und so den leuten die halt von da kommen
die in der scheiße da wohnen oder deiner
scheiße aufgewachsen sind so ihre ihre
ihre wahrheiten so wegnehmen wollen das
finde ich fürchterlich also das ist das
ist das ist ganz ganz ganz ganz
unangenehm so und das eine ist sozusagen
dieses gentrifizierung also aus einem
core tier plötzlich so hippe läden
machen und plötzlich wird er auch sehr
teuer das andere ist ja auch das
romantisieren der arbeiterklasse
arbeiterviertel das ist auch etwas was
der französische schriftsteller edouard
louis immer wieder betont habe und der
immer wieder sagt passt auf wir dürfen
nicht die arbeiter klassifizieren und
romantisieren und ihnen damit eigentlich
ihre stimmen wegnehmen dass ich ja darf
acht jahren werde jetzt total janson
romantisierte sondern romantisierte also
sind es ist ja dieses typische
irgendwelche irgendwelche akademiker
kids die an der uni gehen ihr wg zimmer
bezahlt bekommen man dann irgendwie so
eine offene arme studenten also diese
kacke das ist das ist das ist alles das
ist alles das alles blödsinn so
was ich was ich gerade noch sagen was
weiß ich noch eine interessante facette
an diesem ganzen ding finden an diesem
lifestyle in problembezirken ziehen weil
da gibt's sogar ist falafel und alles so
international und ich bin so weltoffen
dass mich das auch gar nicht stört das
hier so viele araber sind so aber sie
glauben ja nicht ernsthaft dass
irgendeiner von diesen deutschen sein
kind darauf die schule schickt also ich
glaube ich kann schafft dass
irgendwelche
zugezogenen annemaries und fabians
irgendwie ihr kind auf die schule
schicken so zu auf irgendeine schule mit
90 prozent ausländeranteil aber
garantiert nicht das ist halt auch so
was typisch ist und man findet sozusagen
durchmischung genau so lange interessant
wie sie mich nicht in meinem luxus
irgendwie tangiert das ich sozusagen der
vorwurf
ich würde sie gerne auch etwas
persönliches ansprechen nämlich auf
diesen aspekt iwe auf das tattoo
da gibt es nichts spannendes sozusagen
hier 44 doch das interessiert mich auch
weil das ja der titel der der platte ist
von jaycee und das ist ja auch
interessant so dieses
rapido vielleicht auch brav aus
identität kette tragen gewisse sprüche
machen gewisse form von männlichkeit
toxische männlichkeit die da oft in
verbindung gebracht wird aber gerade
jaycee der das er aufgebrochen hat
gerade auf dieser platte er auch zeigt
wie er diese toxische wendigkeit brechen
wegen ist es der kunst darf ich das
wissen schön wäre es aber ich bin
tatsächlich also ich finde sie hat coole
musik gemacht und das album heuer vor
allem das lied fand ich auch cool mochte
primär das artwork ehrlich gesagt und
welche die 44 ist irgendwie wie bezirks
nur von neukölln auch zufällig das war
eigentlich mehr personen so ein gaga
ja aber zum thema für sie oder diese
frage der männlichkeit weil das spielt
immer wieder eine rolle auch in dem
gemisch des hot pot kosten sie haben
vorhin gesagt geschlechterverhältnisse
im studium hat sie auch total
interessiert am anfang überhaupt kein
thema daneben interessiert ist ja auch
klar wenn man sich überlegt wie sie hier
männerbilder schildern und was sie heute
erzählen wie sie sich auch engagieren
für gleichstellung wann ist das schon
etwas aufeinander braun ja also ich bin
mit sehr ambivalenten oder haben werden
weil sie das richtige wort ist aber mit
sehr gegensätzlichen männlichkeits
bildern aufgewachsen weil ich draußen
war es halt einfach diese neukölln macho
scheiße so
aber für mich dadurch dass man also
meine mutter ist er sehr früh gestorben
mein vater hat uns drei kinder alleine
großgezogen großgezogen und war deshalb
auch nicht arbeiten sondern war aus man
also für mich war ein hausmann trotzdem
das normalste der welt dass man den
haushalt macht so und die person die
noch am ehesten eine weibliche
bezugspersonen in meinem leben war es
eine meiner tanten der ist manuela und
die hat immer handwerklich gearbeitet
also ich bin mit also mit so ganz diese
diese rollenbilder frage so ich sehe das
ist ein thema ist und habe in der union
auch noch mal so ein bisschen
sensibilisiert worden auf das thema aber
aus meinem eigenen lebenslauf kann ich
das gar nicht berichten ich habe dieses
extrem neue könige macho mäßige aber
zuhause halt dieses
mann der hausmann ist und die frau die
am erster bezugsperson ins handwerkerin
war also also ich glaube das macht sie
auch so interessant weil ich nämlich
denke wir leben ja in einer zeit dieser
identitätspolitik wo wir sehr stark
diese identitäten haben man ist halt in
dieser schublade oder in dieser
schublade und das zeigt man auch mit den
entsprechenden accessoire den
kleidungsstil welchen kaffee latte
macchiato blablabla man trinkt usw sie
sind eigentlich eine durch und durch
ambivalente persönlichkeit oder so geht
es mir immer wenn ich ihre sachen höhere
anschaue ihre ihre comedy eben auf der
einen seite goldkette und rolex uhr auf
der anderen seite weiß man von ihnen sie
spenden sehr viel sie engagieren sich
sozial darum diese männlichkeits bilder
hier drin gleichzeitig
gleichstellungspolitik also sie passen
eigentlich neben wohin sagen sie auch
von sich selbst sie haben vor eingepasst
na ja ich bin trotzdem immer wieder
verblüfft wie schwer des menschen fällt
diese vermeintlichen wieder sind immer
nur vermeintliche widersprüche so finde
ich diese vermeintlichen widersprüche
irgendwie zusammen zu kriegen und warum
diese
notstandes wort weil ich gelernt habe
ambiguität toleranz so schwer ist für
leute also jeder mensch lebt doch seine
widersprüche und eine komplett
widerspruchsfreie personen ist das
langweiligste was man sich vorstellen
kann und trotzdem ist es immer sehr sehr
schwer für leute irgendwie also ich hab
dann irgendwann für mich selber so
festgestellt okay ich bin irgendwie nah
sie aus berlin aber ich habe trotzdem
spielte und das ok und
und und ich probiere auch nicht
irgendwie also ich hab mal hatte man
eine zeit sondern wollte ich dieses
ganze berlin und pumpen und neukölln so
ein bisschen so weghalten aus meiner
vita dachte mir so weit bin ich entweder
coole student so machen den vier
ohrringe und dass mir die haare wachsen
aber es hat auch nichts geändert ich war
dann trotzdem daran wie gesagt eher der
der der als junger so und dann
irgendwann habe ich gemerkt er okay ich
kann das auch alles einfach authentisch
irgendwie zusammenbringen und
und der erfolg gibt ihm recht ich glaube
sind gerade das was sie gesagt haben
eigentlich ambiguität was macht
eigentlich personen auch interessant da
haben die vielleicht auch wirklich etwas
ein bisschen verloren in unserer
heutigen zeit ist aber komisch also ich
verstehe nicht weil vielleicht hat das
auch was mit social media zu tun oder
sondern bedürfnis nach eindeutigkeit in
einer verwirrenden zeit ich weiß es
nicht vielleicht oder rassismus also
auch sich abgrenzen gegen andere gegen
oben gegen unten was ja auch hilft
identität zu schärfen vielleicht ist es
ein zeichen von verunsicherung diese
antiquität eben nicht auszuhalten ich
glaub fand ganz viele leute finden sich
selber auch einfach total langweilig und
verrennen sich dann einfach in so
irgendeine ideologie welche welche auch
immer also ich glaube viele leute sind
einfach gelangweilt von sich selber und
ihrer normal haid was ich denn
interessant ich ich ich selber finde
mich nicht interessant weil ich weil ich
war dabei
war ja immer dabei aber ich kann
verstehen dass viele leute die halt
einfach so ganz trade aufgewachsen sind
irgendwie kleinstadt beide eltern beide
eltern arbeiten verdient vielleicht in
ordnung hausgarten aber auf dem ersten
bildungsweg studiert so mid mid mid mid
mid mit 17 18 erst mal geburtstag
diese einfach ein normales leben wo es
einfach nie probleme gab so wirklich da
kann ich mir das schon verstehen dass
leute dann mein leben interessant finden
oder ich meine ohne das jetzt in
irgendeiner form vergleichen zu wollen
aber ich meine die leute die gangster
rap damals groß gemacht haben das waren
weiße mittelschicht kids die dann auf
einmal ein double gepumpt haben oder
also die dann einfach so für die war es
halt wie so ein film einfach so
interessant was interessant ist so in
relation zu ihrem eigenen relativ
unspektakulären aber dafür auch probleme
nahmen
konfliktfreien leben und da sehen wir
vielleicht jetzt wirklich bei der comedy
30 ganz am anfang ja gesagt haben
bessere comedy oder bessere comedy zu
machen würde für sie bedeuten immer
stärker oder immer echter an diesen
felix lob recht ranzukommen auf der
bühne in der comedy der felix buck recht
den sie auch sind und vielleicht
sprechen wir wirklich noch ein bisschen
über diese comedy es gab in diesem new
york times artikel gab es diese headline
dass es geheißen habt sie seien ein
smarter misanthrop also eigentlich ein
menschenverachter finden die das
wirklich also ich hatte auch mal so
diese phase wo ich ist und wieso ich
hasse menschen wo ich das so cool fand
so dass einfach so zu klemmen und man
kann auch oft irgendwie an der an
menschen verzweifeln gerade wenn man
irgendwie durchs internet und so
aber die ich ich bin kein misanthrop
ich mag menschen so ich mich berührt das
immer so komisch ist jetzt klingt wenn
man oft wenn ich so auf der straße
einfach so sachen beobachte wo sie
fremde menschen nett zueinander sind das
finde ich immer total total schön zu
sehen sowie einfach irgendeine ich was
meine frau irgendwann eine alte frau
etwas schwerer zu tragen dann kommt
einfach so ein junger typ der aussieht
als würde mit heißen von dem alle denken
würden der der beklaute jetzt und hilft
dir einfach so also so eine sache die
finde ich irgendwie die die ich mag das
einfach wenn sie fremde menschen nett
zueinander sind und ich gebe ja auch
irgendwie mühe im rahmen meiner
möglichkeiten so nett zu leuten zu sein
so diesen eindruck habe ich nämlich auch
und das finde ich interessant gibt
ingolstadt was man sich bestellen kann
hier ein kleines feuerzeug felix loch
recht da steht drauf bin ich nicht der
typ für und ich denke eigentlich felix
toprak ist vor der tür da ist eigentlich
der typ für sehr viele ist also wenn man
guckt worüber sie sprechen im podcast
aber auch in der comedy ich habe das
gefühl eigentlich interessiert sie so
ziemlich alles und sie sind auch
ziemlich aufgeschlossen misanthrop ich
finde ich jetzt ziemlich überraschend ja
ich hab's ja nicht geschrieben
und wenn sie es auf eine formel bringen
müssten wofür sind sie voll der typ
das weiß ich nicht aber also ich kann
ich kann nur sagen was ich
es gibt auch so intension ahl und
extension alle diese definition also
was es nicht ist kann ich bin vielleicht
dazu sagen und das ist auch das was ich
an anderen leuten einfach immer scheisse
finde
geschlechtsunabhängig unabhängig von
allem also ich finde es immer scheiße
wenn leute viel jammern wenn leute ihre
sachen nicht selber also ihre probleme
nicht selber angehen irgendwie
verantwortung delegieren und wenn leute
humorlos sind also
unselbstständigkeit humorlosigkeit und
jammern dass das finde ich finde ich
extrem ab turn und ich achte darauf dass
ich nicht so bin so
bei der comedy geht ja ganz stark darum
immer wieder auch tabus zu brechen das
ist eigentlich der witz des witzes stück
weit und es gibt ja viele witze oder
oder passagen ihrer comedy die röteln
ganz kräftiger und tabus also
beispielsweise machen sich lustig über
behindertenparkplätze gibt es auch
grenzen wo sie sagen diese tabus die
lasse ich tabu sein diese witze sind
tabu für mich
also es gibt jetzt nicht irgendwie das
eine thema wo ich sage darüber würde ich
keine witze machen
ich probiere schon irgendwie auszuloten
also oft ist es ja also oft hab ich
einen guten job zu einer aktuellen
tragödie man denke so noch nicht also
daran später dachte ich dann schon drauf
so weil irgendwie eine sache kann in
einem jahr lustig sein ist aber jetzt
irgendwie vielleicht auch ein sehr guter
job aber einfach so gemein oder ist noch
alles auf sowas 80 aber es gibt jetzt
nicht irgendwie das eine thema wo ich
sage da will ich nicht ran und ich
glaube man kann auch mit also wenn man
ohne zu sagen dass ich das also schon
perfekt kann und das war ja auch das
reich von meinte mit besser werden aber
mit mit einem guten rating und einem und
einer richtigen endet auf der bühne und
so einem feingefühl und irgendwie mit
einem klar machen der perspektive aus
der man den job macht eigentlich überall
so safe über alles witze machen ohne das
es dass es wirklich verletzend ist für
die leute also wenn man sich dieses
behindertenparkplatz mit anguckt was er
auch in dem netflix bachelor sowie den
ausschnitt aus gesehen haben also
natürlich ist es irgendwie konnte sowie
hard und lg daher aber letzten endes
mache ich da witze über ignorante leute
wie mich die sich über ein
behindertenparkplatz aufregen nur weil
sie mit ihrem teuren drecks auto gerade
das hat nicht parken können also es
kommt immer auf die perspektive an aus
der man jobs macht ich finde das sowieso
total interessant ich mein eigentliches
ist ja ein schlaf- und fürs publikum
worüber man lacht also gerade weil das
der tabubruch als witz funktioniert ja
nur wenn die leute das für sich als tabu
empfinden und tabu heißt ja dass man
dinge verdrängen muss also all die leute
die in dem moment lachen die explodieren
sozusagen das was ich vorhin runter
gedrückt haben dass ich ja die humor
theorie bei sigmund freud also dieses
aufwand ersparnis wir lachen damit wir
nicht unseren unsere eifersucht unsere
eigentlichkeit weiter unten drückt nach
unten drücken müssen deswegen lassen wir
das heißt wenn die leute lachen wenn sie
es genau anzeichen dafür dass sie
eigentlich diese gefühle haben dass sie
nämlich eigentlich gerne oder dass sie
sagt dass sie sich erkennen in diesen
sachen genau so und ich finde humor und
lachen ist einfach das beste mittel zur
emotionalen verarbeitung von allem
möglichen
also ich glaube
nichts ist besser dafür geeignet und mit
schlimmen sachen auch umzugehen als als
humor so und
ja ich finde
mir ist auch kunst im weiteren sinne
lieber die vielleicht mal übers ziel
hinausschießt als eine kunst die es gar
nicht erst probiert die gar nicht erst
los läuft dann immer schön so denn so da
können sich alle darauf einigen sodann
da stößt sich keine kätzchen irgendwie
die foto das er ist er total langweilig
also dann dann lieber mal irgendwie ein
schutzraum in kauf nehmen oder x oder
mal übers ziel hinausschießen aber dass
man so ein bisschen
voran kommt hier mit dem laden hier aber
sie selber habe noch nie ein shitstorm
gekriegt oder doch natürlich aber nicht
viele so gecancelt oder so was würden
sie auch noch nie habe ich den eindruck
dass ist dass er noch mal ganz anderes
thema also ich hatte viele schütz doms
und ich habe irgendwann aufgehört
ich habe unseren twitter gelöscht und
seitdem ist das problem auch nicht mehr
meinem leben so
es gibt aber es ist interessant also in
einem moment hatte ich irgendwie ein
riesenschritt zum am laufen wegen
irgendwas und dann in diesen situationen
die unangenehm sind so dann gehe ich
einfach raus und
dann merkt man im echten leben auch ich
wurde ganz weit nach dem foto gefragt
und alle hier gehört ein podcast oder
voll cool dass man bei so und da merkt
man das ist auch alles sehr viel einfach
internet es ist auch nicht echt aber
trotzdem mussten wir auch mal zwei
wochen lang schoss unter unter
polizeischutz spielen weil es und wieso
anschlagsdrohung auf eine auf eine
komplette tour von mir gab von
irgendwelchen leuten so also das ist das
ist das ist so beides aber
trotzdem bevor man dann irgendwie diese
art comedy in anführungszeichen macht
über die ich vorhin gemeckert hat
nämlich die die eigentlich nur noch
message und nur noch das sagen was alle
sowieso hören wollen ist dann nehme ich
lieber so was einkaufen jetzt haben sie
vorhin gesagt sie mögen kunst die sich
riskiert und überhaupt sei eben humor
auch als ein risiko zu pflegen wenn sie
auch sagen ironie oder humor ist sowas
wie ne lebenshaltung finde ich schon
deshalb war es auch vorhin in meinem was
ich nicht gut finde also was ich immer
scheiße von den leuten das
humorlosigkeit das muss ganz schlimm
sein wenn man einfach
nicht lacht man einfach so in allem
immer die schwere sieht und nicht
vielleicht auch das den lustigen aspekt
oder so dass also ich finde das ist auf
jeden fall auf eine art ein
lebenskonzept ich wollte noch eine sache
sagen zudem davor also ich find
provokation nur der provokation willen
auch langweilig also jetzt einfach nur
irgendwie möglichst oft zu sagen um
irgendwie zu schocken das finde ich auch
langweilig es muss schon irgendwie
gedanke dahinter hängen der irgendwie
nachvollziehbar ist oder der smart ist
oder einfach eine sache die innung nach
form war ist auch wenn sie nicht schön
ist sodann kann man da und der job muss
gut sein also je härter das thema das
wasser der jobs ist eine comedy
faustregel so also das ist schon wichtig
dass dieses stumpfe provozieren das
finde ich auch langweilig aber ja ich
glaube eben weil humor wie ich wie ich
gerade schon meint in meinen augen ein
sehr gutes tool ist um einfach alles
mögliche emotional zu verarbeiten ist
daraus abgeleitet humor wahrscheinlich
auch eine art lebenshaltung oder 5 4 was
auch immer ich verstehe das sehr gut und
das spricht mir aus dem herzen so dieses
gefühl der ironischen distanz die einem
hilft im leben auch sich selbst nicht so
wahnsinnig tierisch ernst zu nehmen und
zugleich finde ich immer es ist auch
eine hohe kunst das leben trotzdem ernst
zu nehmen und zwar gerade auch die
schattenseiten weil ich am anfang jahr
über diese live hacks ausgesprochen
haben und darüber davon immer alles
gleich weg machen und ich finde es geht
auch darum auszuhalten dass dinge
schwierig sind wir finden hier da die
balance zwischen dieser ironischen
distanz humorvoll und gleichzeitig ernst
nehmen was da abgeht
weiß nicht ich auch nicht ich weiß nicht
was nicht das ist ja irgendwie auch
keinen kein bewusster prozess so ich
glaube halt nur bei sachen nicht schön
sind sind sie dadurch nicht weniger wahr
so das ist einfach nur sache die man
irgendwie so im kopf behalten muss
irgendwie
und ja also wie gesagt comedy es einfach
ein cooles tool oder humors und cooles
tool manchmal sachen so aufs wesentliche
runter zu kochen und dann ist es
irgendwie meistens ich hatte irgendwie
so denn dass ihr habt ja auch manchmal
gedankenexperimente so dass man
eigentlich egal wo man anfängt zu denken
wenn man das einfach so konsequent
weiterdenkt kommt man irgendwann immer
an dem punkt der sms irgendwie albern
irgendwie alles also wir sind ja ich
meine die essenz ist ja ist ja irgendwie
sehr alles albernste relativierung zur
er genau also ist man und
rassismus der zionismus hat er noch so
was
also etwas bösartiges noch so ein
bisschen
also war sowas lebens verneinen dass ich
glaube man kann auch lebensbejahend zu
dem punkt kommen ist doch albern so im
sinne von also so schlimm ist es nicht
wenn man mal raussuchen vielleicht ganz
zum schluss sie beenden ja ihr letztes
comedy-programm haid damit dass sie
sagen dass sie eigentlich zum ersten mal
im leben verlustängste haben als sie
denken es gibt unglaublich viel zu
verlieren es gibt überhaupt irgendwas zu
verlieren also ich glaube der satz ist
ich hab es erst noch einen verlust für
das erste mal in meinem leben was
verlieren hat
einfach den job den ich gerade
mache und die möglichkeiten die er mir
bietet so dass also das war jetzt um
eine größte verlustangst das ist nicht
so sehr was ökonomisches weil ich bin
auch 27 jahre ohne geld klar gekommen
und ich verdiene mein eigenes geld seit
ich 16 bin ich weiß wenn ich jetzt kein
geld mehr hätte würde ich schon wieder
irgendwie klarkommen so dass das ist
nicht das ding aber einfach so dieses
ich mag mein leben und mein job das ich
machen kann was ich will dass ich mein
eigener chef bin dass ich irgendwie die
möglichkeit habe dass mein bruder fest
bei mir arbeitet das ich
mitarbeiterinnen habe die irgendwie fest
bei mir arbeiten können dass ich eine
crew habe die davon leben können dass
ich meinem vater monatlich geld geben
kann dass man irgendwo irgend etwas
anbrennt in meinem näheren umkreis dass
ich schon aus helfen kann so also diese
sachen geben mir viel und machen wir
machen hier spaß und das zu verlieren
davor habe ich mal mehr und mal weniger
angst als ich die jobs damals
geschrieben hatte war es sehr akut weil
das zweite programm gerade neu rauskam
und ich das gefühl hat also jetzt gibt
es ja das erste mal so ein spotlight auf
mich auch wenn es noch ein kleineres war
als vielleicht heute aber es gibt jetzt
irgendwie eindruck und eine
erwartungshaltung und wenn man jetzt und
wenig liefert dann dann ist es vorbei so
und aus also als ich die jobs oder
dieses ende geschrieben hat war sehr
echt und irgendwann habe ich dann halt
drin gelassen wenn es dann vielleicht
auch manchmal nicht so akut war aber es
ist wie so ein ich habe das mal
verglichen mit sowie werden irgendwie
musikern liebeslied schreibt über seinen
liebeskummer so und dann wird es wird
das ding hier dann singt er das trotzdem
noch wenn er gerade irgendwie glücklich
einer neuen beziehung ist und zwei
kinder hat ich hoffe auf jeden fall sie
keinen alters noch ganz lange behalten
was sie haben und wie er damit auch sie
vielen herzlichen dank dass sie bei uns
waren felix luz recht hat eine frau
bosch und ich wollte noch mal sagen
stand schon philosophie ist mein
absoluter liebling sendung fast jeder
folge geführt ja und wir verlosen drei
exemplare der graphic novel sonne und
beton soeben erschienen natürlich
signiert von felix lotrecht teilnehmer
der verlosung kann ich auf meinem
instagram account oder auf der sendung
seite der sternstunde philosophie am
nächsten sonntag spricht wolfram
eilenberger mit der spanischen
philosophin elisabeth die wahl darüber
wie es ist sich im körper eines mannes
aus frau zu erkennen existenziell sozial
und rechtlich eine frage die zurzeit
auch in der schweiz kontrovers
diskutiert wird und jetzt gleich wie
jetzt boomt die us amerikanerin georgia
o keeffe die welt so wie sie da und zwar
anders als alle andern ihre farbenfrohen
blumen will das sind heute kohlen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
lassen sie es blühen eine gute woche
[Musik]